Can you shut up so that I can speak?
Shut up, please.
I want to say that what you see in Gaza now
is an act of genocide
because 12,000 children have been killed.
And these are not 19 years old.
These are 5,
6 years old
and 3 years old
and 2 years old.
These are children,
for God's sake!
I am against the killing of 30 Israeli children,
which happened on October 7th,
because they are children and civilians.
But nothing in the world could justify
because of the killing of 30 children,
the killing of 12,000 other Palestinian children.
That is unacceptable.
I am a. You should look at the real figures.
30,000 Palestinian civilians have been killed
and 72,000 people have been Israelis. 30,000.
This is 4.5% of the population.
Hold on, hold on.
I did not interrupt you,
so shut up and let me finish.
4.5% of the population of Gaza
have been killed or injured.
If that had happened in the United States of America,
you would be talking about 12 million people
killed or injured in four months of time.
Is that acceptable?
And mostly civilians.
70% are civilians.
More than that,
Israel is killing Palestinians.
Not only with this terrible genocide,
with their bombardment.
They are killing Palestinians with starvation,
this terrible siege.
50,000 pregnant women,
Palestinian women don't find a place to give birth in.
64,000 breastfeeding women cannot help their babies.
And more than that,
700,000 people are now starving
because Israel is Preventing milk,
flour, food to the population of Gaza City
and the north of Gaza.
And more than that,
they shoot the Palestinian hungry people
when they are trying to get some food.
Okay, Mr. Bugutin.
Like they did two days ago.
100. 100 people and 860 others.
We're injured.
So my response to you. Yes,
this is genocide.
These are three war crimes happening at the same time.
Genocide, collective punishment,
and ethnic cleansing.
At the same time.
70% of all homes were destroyed,
all universities were destroyed.
30 hospitals out of 36 hospitals were destroyed.
347 of my colleagues,
medical doctors